Alice is facing the issue that her simple algorithm while it's correct
does not show an acceptable running time so we should probably say a little bit more as to
what we would consider an acceptable running time, like here
and what we would consider an unacceptable running time.
And in theoretical computer science or at least for the first units of this course,
we're just making a distinction between two cases basically.
The first case here is polynomial running time.
And polynomial running time means that the algorithm has a running time that can be stated as
some polynomial of the size of the input.
So, polynomial time would be an algorithm that has a running time of O(n), O(n²),
but even with an algorithm with a running time such as O(n¹⁰) or worse
would be considered a polynomial time algorithm
and we would say that the running time of this algorithm is more less acceptable.
Now, exponential running time, those are algorithms that have n in the exponent of their running time.
So, O(2ⁿ) would be an algorithm that's exponential running time.
O(1.1ⁿ) would be an algorithm with exponential running time
and also something really bad such as O(10ⁿ) that would also be an exponential running time.
What about an algorithm such as O(3ⁿn²), that would also be called exponential running time
because as you saw in previous quizzes, the 3ⁿ is the fastest growing term here.
So, the dominant term here is an exponential term.
So, running times like this would also fall under exponential running time.